Seth Davis is kind enough to join us CBS
sports college basketball analyst and he
got roughed up a little bit for his
tweet about the FBI's investigation into
college basketball the pay-for-play
scandal and this has to do with you know
Kansas is involved in then you got other
programs you got Arizona involved in
this Seth Davis tweeted out for two
years the FBI used every investigative
technique at its disposal to dig into
corruption in college basketball and the
biggest fish they caught we're Christian
Dawkins Jim Gatto and book Richardson
maybe the sport is actually cleaner than
we thought were you joking about this
Seth more than dad tell you something
you know how exhausting it is being the
smartest guy on Twitter it is it is it
is a full-time job that's why I'm not on
Twitter so you can be the smartest guy
on Twitter right I was not joking first
and foremost let me say it's running
joke between us when I say you know I in
my spot saying I love you I do love you
and I thank you for what you said
yesterday bringing in your radio family
to what you're going through and I'm
praying for you I know that you're gonna
be just fine with all of us thank you
for doing that hmm
here's here's my point you know we
talked about tie I use the words college
basketball maybe college basketball is
cleaner than we think
whom are we talking about when we're
talking about college basketball the
guys that I name you know Christian
Dawkins Jim Dodd oh these assistant
coats are they college basketball I
think when most people think about
college basketball we're talking about
players and head coaches and if you go
back to the press conference at the
Southern District of New York held a
year and a half ago they made a big show
of this thing when they had the initial
arrests we have your playbook we're
taking the whole thing down I am
convinced I know this based on my
reporting that they believe that that
was only the beginning of what they
thought it would be a process that would
lead to the big names does remember now
they are they are not differentiating
between n-c-double-a violations and
federal crimes they are saying that
committing these violations is a crime
because you are in effect defrauding the
school
so the only thing that I'm trying to say
I didn't say college basketball was
clean but they have wiretaps and
informants no tools the entity could
only dream of having and what have they
really turned out like what content they
turned up we have booked Richardson an
assistant coach for Arizona telling
Christian Dawkins who is an aspiring
agent who is a known liar and has
committed malfeasance on a lot of levels
against employers and the like saying
that Sean Miller
personally pays DeAndre eight and ten
grand a month
well they yes yeah wiretap these guys
phones why don't they have Sean melon on
a wiretap saying these things if the
Southern District of New York do you
think they want to put Christian Dawkins
away they thought they were getting Sean
Miller they thought they were getting
Bill Self they thought they were getting
so if they have this evidence Sean
Miller would be a defendant in this
trial so look I'll believe anything I'll
believe that it's possible that Sean did
this but just show me the proof show me
the evidence there's financial records
there's wires transfers there's bank
statements the FBI has access to all
this Sean Miller such a good money
launderer that he can hide paying a
player ten grand a month and Christian
Dawkins talent book Richardson oh you
know Sean told me this so I'm grilling
those Christian Dawkins he's not a big
player in this space
if Sean Miller's Pantheon drew eight and
10 grand a month you think he's going to
tell that to Christian Dawkins yeah but
he said it they said under oath no sir
he said it under oath well I made people
lie under oath all the time you know
what he said well Christian Dawkins is
saying but why is it on the wiretap no
where's the corroborating evidence and
if the FBI believes that sir why isn't
someone below that defendant here so
well okay let me ask you this though
Seth let me ask you think DeAndre Aiden
was paid to go to Arizona I'm answering
that question with my quote from Tom
Cruise from a few good men don't tell me
what I know tell me what I can prove all
believe that all can see that it's
possible okay I can see that it's
possible okay
I mean you can think that it's likely I
maybe think that it's highly probable
show me the proof and that's fair so
when people say well yeah and that's all
I'm saying
and for a year and a half the FBI
wiretap these cars phones and I know for
a fact it's on Miller's on wiretap
because they have to be notified by a
law if you're caught on a wiretap even
if you're sending something benign so
I'm just saying this is what they have
this is everything that they have this
notion that these trials are going to
happen and all these crazy things on
wiretaps are going to show up I mean
that only happens on on TV so that
that's all I'm saying here and you know
show me the post on these things and and
and we'll follow the facts and that's
why we'll wait until the coaches LSU and
that's why Sean Miller still the coach
at Arizona because there has to be an
actual finding so when the NCAA moves in
on all this they're able to take the
evidence from the trial but they need
corroborating evidence they can't just
take Christian Dawkins word that Sean
Miller told him that he paid DeAndre
Aten for them to have an actual finding
that Arizona can access on Miller's
concert because of this finding you are
in our fire we're talking to Seth Davis
CBS sports college basketball analyst
and great writer great author I'm also
curious about this because there has
been documentation of an ask price for
Zion Williamson at Kansas correct well
again we documentation well there was a
report there are there was a report
right there was there was a okay then
there was an asking price for Zion
Williamson to go to Kansas correct that
that was stated on a wiretap between
somebody and Curtis Townsend who was an
assistant of Kansas so whether or not we
don't have the actual ask
we have someone saying I heard there was
an ask because what we have to remember
then is that everybody everybody in this
mix that they all have these agendas but
so again Christian Dawkins is somebody
who's trying to build an agency because
we probably he got fired from his own
agency because he was caught using
Alford Peyton's credit card to
fraudulent run of $42,000 of uber
charges how anybody charged gets up to
42,000 over anyway I was taking rights
to Alaska or what he was doing but he's
easily
liar and a fraud on a lot of these
levels I think what happens is a lot of
these guys talk to each other and say I
know Pitino I know so I heard sirens
getting 10th out you got to give me 20
so I can get yours on there's a lot of
that stuff going on now what I believe
that died Williamson got money of course
I would believe that what I believe that
Marvin Bagley got money of course I
would believe that don't tell me what
you think don't tell me what you know
don't tell me what you believe tell me
what I can prove at the end of the day
that's what this comes down to what is
the evidence and what can we prove Thank
You Seth it's great to talk to you Dan
Patrick I love you thank you for having
thank you but that's a Seth Davis CBS
sports college basketball analyst yeah I
understand what he's saying
you know you want to have that evidence
would I be surprised with any of this
what I surprised DeAndre Aiden was paid
to there I'd be surprised if he wasn't
paid in Arizona I'd be surprised if
these kids in Kansas weren't paid by
somebody somehow I would be surprised if
Zion Williamson or his family was not
paid for him to just stay in college
basketball for a year I'm not surprised
at any of this but I do think that
college basketball while we want to say
oh look at these you know pillars of
integrity on the sidelines they're you
know John Wooden is the pillar of
integrity in a lot of people's minds in
code you know the coaching basketball
even coaching any sport and he looked
the other way when you had a boost you
had the sugar daddy there at UCLA it
happens because their their motives that
are there and they're not always
altruistic you know you have people with
agendas
you know you get coaches who come with
players hey if I'll I'll bring in this
kid but you gotta bring in the assistant
coach he needs a job too
there's so many people involved in it
then there's so many layers to it I'm
not surprised at any of it does anybody
get popped for this maybe not
it doesn't mean college basketball is
clean or cleaner than we thought four
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on VR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app